あっ方うーんちょっとなんかもろすぎですよ
はずの流氷から起きてるはず3冊にめっちゃかけして弾いて欲しい方は春馬ないあっ
ほい
うーん
をへわかりました今日は外せそうです皆さんおっしゃらねー
好きですよね押されてバイブで服とかだと思うんですけど僕際にしろこの服しか着ない
でちょっともの
もどっプロドーンの空6が男性そんなを装って再掲し生活してるんですけども逆に逆に
もっと騎馬図の方に降ったらもっとれ目立てるんじゃないかと思いましてやばい服
見つけてきましたこちらです
なんかちらっと見たんですけどもつかまだねこの秋雑然だがそんなに分からないんです
よすごく開けます
電話なんかねっ
妻は放ってるよねなんか雑感もやっとした感じますけどこれすごいらしいですよ
これがまず
したらパンツねっ
ブーバーしますけどまだ所々テカテカする感じがしますねそしてこのご時世ということ
でマースクもありますね行っ oe いたって普通のマスクっぽいんですけどもこの日
ありますと再帰性反射
というなんか技術を使った服らしくて光いって高反射するじゃないですか
鏡とかて来て反射するでしょ再帰性反射とは受けた光同じ角度で高原にはね返さ反射
現象のことで
んだからわからないけどなんか機会が来たらその方向で跳ね返す特殊素材になってみ
たいです
なんか説明のためにも書いてあるんですけども光が反射するので名札しさて束すると
すげー光るらしいですぞさっそく着てみましょうか
う
tee
me
ています
dea
講習やってみたかったん
[音楽]
大
さでですねマンのパッと見普通なんですけどこれまずフラッシュと変わってるとほんと
すごいらしいんですよ
別のまだわからんだろう
一回やってみましょうん
来たれ家木カメやそこはん
ています
宇部西上杉はだったスポーンとを買った
うわぁ
みてくださいこれ待ってちょっと
マネージャー先取ってもらおう
はいはい
[音楽]
あつってきてございますっっ
上アワー e 8 f 風芸
みてください後年間本当なんかこういう服なんですけど今とれたチンコズーって初たい
ん
翌朝なくてもできるんかな暗い場所なのは勝ったけどわから良い場所でどうにかさっき
いるのか
明るくてもなるか開かなくてもすごいなこれええ
すごいテンションめっちゃ上がってきたんだけどちょっと舵取りとかしてもさーい
あすごいすごいすごいまずいところが見ててねカメラ普通でしょうから
普通でしょ
ポルトこうどうなってる
こうなるんでしょえっええ
ただ俺これ育てるときマスクをつけるんですよこれまずくっつけて取ると思うそれこそ
大事なことがありますけど大丈夫ですか
いい
[音楽]
ん
あっ方も増えず護衛インスタ映えしそう
まあ in サークルをやっておりますのでぜひ皆さん4をお願いしますこれすごい
というわけでパッドり普通の服に見えると思うんですけど
フラッシュ焚いて写真撮ってからようやく凄さがわかる服なんで今キャラ
今から2あるユーチューバーとこいつに撮影しに行ってくるんですけども記念撮影で
フラ車体に取った時に俺だけ異常な花茶屋清瀬したらどういう反応するのか
てもらいましょう良いよ
にもんだっ版という
こっちおけ数こっち
あれでは古いなんだこれいい感じなんですか
安保こっちではい
お久しぶりですおしゃれを待ってろマッハ
願いしまーすすいません佳作ですよろしくお願い少々邪魔しますはい
いきなりなんですねー
写真撮れませんが一緒に
はい写真等ハウゼ月とさせべほんともう
はねとび世代で名作好きなそうなんでしょうねあの肇社長さんが言ってくださって手前
なんとか共演させていただいたさんいうのがありましてですね写真
写真と思ったの記念でぜひあのはいいいですか
[音楽]
から待ってるんですこれ待ってます
それは超豊満当社何にも聞いてなくてなきゃいられなんだよ車
はい
[音楽]
思います
入った
凄いぜますよ4に戻ってきましたよっ
この camera う
i チーズ
朝一ん
はいますありがとうございます
[音楽]
ああどうすかねぇ
あんあんちょっ暗くないですか
そのライト的に
[音楽]
ねこれふっ
なにこれ
どうぞ
-5
[笑い]
ブーバーし
だからずっとクラブして噂だったらもう1回僕のリアクションをとりなをさせてもらっ
たから
あと広いねやっちゃ
すごいビアチャンさんで今ぼくワーッと来やしませんか
はっはっは
ちょっと社長さんが2時間てますやんとか言ったほうが良かったぞ受け付けます
えっ
絶望先生お願いますはい写真たい行きましょう
あざがあります
ですけれど問題とかなければも戦前
者社長さんが僕だけめちゃ怒ってますよ
なんですよねこれ